[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous nous allons
évoquer ici des sujets stratégiques et
sur des dossiers sensibles
je vais partager mon interprétation vous
avez sans doute assister en étant
confiné à la cérémonie du 8 mai vous
avez entendu le discours du chef de
l'état et celui du président trump et
dans ce cas comme moi vous avez dû vous
poser des questions
[Musique]
permettez moi un rappel historique pour
ceux qui ignorent cette période la
guerre en europe ne s'est pas terminée
le 8 mai le 7 mai 1945 à 2h41 par la
signature de la capitulation à reims par
le maréchal allemand alfred jodl en
présence du généraux américains walter
bedell smith et eisenhower du général
français cévennes et du général
soviétique sousse lobanov mais staline
dont les troupes partie de stalingrad
occupé la capitale du reich voulait
absolument consignes à berlin c'est
pourquoi on a organisé une nouvelle
signature le 8 mai à 23h16 au quartier
général des troupes rue du maréchal
joffre dans ce qui deviendra berlin est
elle sera faite par le maréchal allemand
wilhelm keitel en présence des
représentants des etats-unis de la
grande-bretagne et de la france
mais à moscou avec le décalage horaire
on n'était plus le 8
on était le 9 mai au matin et c'est pour
ça que depuis les fêtes de la
commémoration de la fin de la guerre et
de la signature de la capitulation
allemande sont fêtés le 9 mai en russie
quand ils sont fêtés le 8 mai chez les
alliés alors que les alliés l'avait
officiellement signé le 7
alors à partir de cette date les deux
principaux alliés le président américain
franklin roosevelt et staline avec la
bénédiction du troisième homme
le premier ministre anglais winston
churchill qui voulait garder son empire
allait se répartir l'europe selon les
accords qu'ils avaient passé moins d'un
an plus tôt à yalta en crimée à la
grande fureur du général de gaulle
[Musique]
j'ai écouté notre président en parler
des alliés en termes généraux puis la
reine elizabeth qui est la seule à avoir
connu cette époque de la victoire en
europe des hommes et des femmes du pays
et de l'étranger
j'ai ensuite écouté le président trup
pratiquer le déni en oubliant carrément
l'allier qui a eu le triste privilège
d'avoir le plus grand nombre de morts
dans la deuxième guerre mondiale
pourtant ce ne fut pas de guerre séparé
qui mirent à genoux l'allemagne mais
bien une seule menée sur deux fronts
celui de l'ouest par les alliés
occidentaux et celui de l'est par
l'allié soviétique
je n'ai pu m'empêcher de penser aux
pilotes français des escadrilles du
groupe normandie niemen envoyés par de
gaulle pour aider nos alliés installé
sur la base ivanovo prennent moscou en
novembre 42
ils se sont couverts de gloire pendant
toute la guerre en multipliant sur leurs
chasseurs yak les victoires en combat
aérien contre les méchants ce mythe de
la luftwaffe
beaucoup sont morts pour la défense d'un
monde qu'ils voulaient libres et ont été
enterrés sur place
mais si j'ai bien compris ils sont morts
pour rien puisque au nom d'une idéologie
on nie leur existence en oubliant une
partie de la guerre même si ce n'est ni
la première ni la dernière fois qu'on
veut tordre la vérité des faits il est
légitime de se poser des questions
certes la mémoire est sélective et ne
garder que les bons moments mais nous
avons tous appris que l'identité d'un
peuple se construit à partir de son
environnement de sa culture et de son
histoire
[Musique]
les idéologues d'aujourd'hui qui veulent
réécrire l'histoire d'hier en fonction
de leurs analyses et de la volonté de
faire passer leurs convictions
politiques le savent bien ils font tout
pour faire oublier ou pour dévaloriser
ce qui ne va pas dans le sens de
l'histoire auquel il se réfère bien que
personne ne sache où il est ils oublient
que l'on fédère une nation autour de
grands desseins ecomotive un peuple par
sa fierté d'appartenance les peuples
sans histoires sont des peuples sans à
venir défier dry shine games
c'est ainsi que dans certains manuels de
cours d'histoire de nos enfants on veut
faire oublier napoléon bonaparte chef de
guerre et grand organisateur de l'état
moderne au profit de robespierre
le père de la terreur ou gracchus babeuf
hamid mara est précurseur du communisme
on veut faire passer la colonisation
française comme une exploitation
génocidaire cantou montre qui a eu pas
mal de problèmes mais aussi beaucoup de
réussite
il faut relire les déclarations des
anciens chefs de la rébellion algérienne
après l'indépendance
quand ils ont été rejetés du pays par
les politiques du front de libération
nationale qui eux n'avaient pas fait la
guerre sur place eux ont eu le courage
de dire que tout n'était pas mauvais
dans la colonisation
il y avait bien sûr et comme toujours du
noir et du blanc mais entre nous ce fut
le cas également après l'histoire est
plus compliquée que certains veulent
nous le faire croire
il faut réserver le manichéisme à star
wars et aux films de cow-boys la réalité
plus complexe vouloir à la réécrire pour
ferrer by oublier les échecs ou des
périodes qui déplaisent ne permet pas de
comprendre ce qui s'est vraiment passé
alors ne laissons pas mourir l'histoire
en la laissant travestir au gré des
vainqueurs ou des idéologies
[Musique]
à dire vrai ce n'est pas la première
fois que l'on veut oublier des parties
de l'histoire car elle empêche de
recueillir seul les lauriers de la
gloire
faisant partie d'une famille chez qui le
gaullisme était un sacerdoce
j'ai toujours su que le 18 juin le
général de gaulle avait fait l'appel de
londres que l'on connaît après avoir
obtenu l'autorisation de churchill je me
souviens de ma surprise quand j'ai
découvert que sept jours plus tard le 25
juin 40
les principaux chefs des services de
renseignement et contre espionnage
français de la france occupée
le colonel river et le commandant
payolle avaient tous leurs officiers
firent le serment de continuer la lutte
contre les forces ennemies et mirent en
place les premières actions de
résistance et les filières d'information
vers les alliés avec de nombreuses
pertes et des réussite indéniable
l'organisation a survécu à tout la
guerre
leur seul tort fut de ne pas être du bon
côté identifié comme vichyste puis comme
giraud dist alors qu'ils avaient la
france au coeur il a fallu deux
générations avant qu'on reconnaisse avec
difficulté qu'ils furent des précurseurs
dans la lutte contre les nazis
on préfère croire que tout a commencé
exclusivement avec le général et le
grand public ne sait toujours pas on l'a
vu aussi pour le réseau alliances de
marie madeleine fourcade parce qu'il
travaillait pour les services anglais
on l'a vu enfin par les hommes et les
femmes parachuté en france par le
special operations executive britannique
c'est à dire la branche actions du
service britannique où l'eau ss
américain l'organisation des tra tjx
taux 10 qui était lui aussi l'émanation
des services américains et dont la
reconnaissance comme combattant fut
toujours difficile après la guerre comme
disait mon ami
malheureusement défunt bob maloubier
commandeur de l'empiré britannique deux
fois parachuté en france ayant survécu à
sa propre exécution on faisait ce qui
nous semblait bien pour gagner la guerre
sans se poser de questions ah il en
attendait pas de la reconnaissance
mais de là à oublier
tout à l'heure j'ai évoqué le 7 mai qui
se souvient encore que le 7 mai 1954
dans la cuvette de dien bien phu en
indochine
l'armée française a subi sa plus grande
défaite de l'histoire moderne face au
général giap grand admirateur de
napoléon iii 1300 militaires sont morts
ou disparus sur le champ de bataille et
11300 on oublie trop souvent dans les
camps de prisonniers du vietminh
aujourd'hui on rend hommage à chaque
soldat tué en opérations extérieures
mais n'aurait-il pas été normale au nom
du devoir de mémoire de penser aussi à
tous ceux qui disparurent ces jours là
dans la fournaise loin de la terre
natale certes ce fut une défaite on
n'aime pas les défaites et de surcroît
cette guerre était impopulaire les
blessés au combat se faisait insulter
quand on est débarqué à marseille
mais est ce une raison pour oublier
leurs sacrifices et faire fi du devoir
de mémoire comme l'a magnifiquement
rappelé le général dary
dans un article récent le 8 mai est un
hommage à tous les soldats inconnus et
me fait se souvenir de ce poème des
légionnaires qui sait si l'inconnu qui
dort sous l'arche immense béland sa
gloire épique aux orgueil du passé n'est
pas cet étranger devenu fils de france
non par le sang reçu mais par le sang
versé
ce magnifique poème écrit par pascal
bonetti en 1920 dans ce cadre on honore
la france qui se bat celle de tous les
combattants ceux qui sont tombés dans
les opérations extérieures comme tous
ceux hommes et femmes des plus humble au
plus haut qui sont tombés pour nous
défendre dans la lutte contre le coc
ville 19
il faut saluer leurs engagements et ne
pas les oublier une fois le confinement
terminé en faisant ou en laissant
réécrire l'histoire par les politiques
ou les laboratoires pharmaceutiques
[Musique]
dans le fond dans le monde d'aujourd'hui
les pires ennemis sont l'oubli et
l'indifférence
nous vivons le moment présent comme une
éternité sans connaissance du passé et
sans vision d'avenir au nom d'une
idéologie égocentriste bien que
mondialistes nous ne voulons regarder
que nous même admirer avec raison les
actes souvent héroïques des combattants
de la résistance comme l'on l'a décrit
pierre nord dans son livre sur les morts
de cette époque ne doit pas nous faire
oublier les combats des partisans du
cren dont parle si bien fedorov dans son
livre quand il livré bataille contre les
divisions allemandes
ce n'est pas se rabaisser que de
reconnaître le courage des autres quels
qu'ils soient
c'est au contraire un moyen de
comprendre la fraternité qui existent
entre les compagnons d'armes et le
respect entre les combattants
mais revenons au discours du président
entre pouvoir faire oublier son
principal allié
pendant la guerre montre une volonté
hégémonique de s'affirmer comme unique
comme irremplaçables on peut le
comprendre quand on sait les difficultés
actuelles de nos amis d'outre-atlantique
certes on peut diverger sur les moyens
les approches les stratégies on peut
également se brouiller sur des
divergences ou des oppositions mais on
ne peut pas faire table rase du passé
car le passé existent pour toujours
quand on efface une image sur son
ordinateur il reste toujours une copie
quelque part et les moeurs sera un jour
en étant utilisé pour des raisons bonnes
ou mauvaises soyez en sûr la conquête de
l'amérique s'est faite au détriment des
populations indiennes qui habitaient le
pays
voulant faire oublier cette colonisation
brutale qu'aujourd'hui on pourra
appellerait un génocide
hollywood par de nombreux films à
justifier leur élimination en les
montrant méchant et sauvage mais
aujourd'hui les temps changent
ils sont devenus des êtres humains
fréquentable avec une histoire et une
culture
la vérité finit toujours par émergent au
nom du devoir de mémoire il faut savoir
dépasser ses victoires et ses défaites
pour se retrouver tous ensemble pour
honorer tous ceux qui sont morts pour
défendre leur idéal fait d'une certaine
idée de leur pays et du partage de
valeurs essentielles le devoir de
mémoire en réalité c'est la
reconnaissance de l'udm comme élément
essentiel de ce que nous sommes
à bientôt
[Musique]